At the end of the last lesson and now with Grant's latest issue as well, we've
seen that sometimes parabolas don't have two real roots. Remember that a root is
a value for x that satisfies a quadratic equation. Now, there's a single part of
the quadratic formula that we can look at to determine how many real roots of
parabola will have. That expression is called the discriminate. Just to remind
you, here's the general form for a quadratic equation, and the quadratic formula
for calculating the roots of that equation. Knowing that the discriminate on
it's own is what determines the number of real roots, which of the following
expressions down here do you think is a discriminate? Is it negative b, negative
b plus or minus the square root of b squared minus 4ac, b squared negative 4ac,
b squared minus 4ac, or 2a?